well i mean i personally value  traditional gender roles right i think  the most beautiful thing a woman can do  is be a mother and  raise children and have a family  and  excuse this term but serve her husband  right like i personally think that  that's sort of  serve as in make his life um as easy as  possible right because he's the one  that's paying for everything and my  brother's in the room and we were  talking about this earlier today gideon  goes i just want my woman to cook me  bacon and eggs and i'll pay for  everything all i'm asking is for bacon  and eggs and a clean house i think it's  true look if he's gonna pay for  everything then why are you upset